the future is here it's just not evenly
distributed look around the world and we
know this to be true you're all here in
this room
chances are the vast majority of you got
in a regular gasoline-powered vehicle
and drove here to the venue today
however we know that in the future many
of us will be driving electric vehicles
clean electric vehicles those electric
vehicles may be using power that came
from dirty coal so how clean is that
electric vehicle well that's also
becoming a salt problem in California
today you could use a company like Solar
City to go install solar panels on your
roof that look like legitimate roofing
this isn't an eyesore it's just your
entire roof is a solar panel pretty
amazing future that's already here if
you're in California today completely
off the grid we know that today if you
go to the grocery store the vast
majority of us have this as our reality
we wait in line to check out however if
you're lucky enough to be in Seattle
near the very first Amazon go store
there is no such thing as a line there's
no such thing as a checkout you grab
what you need and you walk out the door
and sensors charge you accordingly the
future is already here it's just not
evenly distributed and this principle of
course applies to JavaScript as well the
future of JavaScript is here it's not
evenly distributed and I'm going to ask
you a few questions during this session
that's going to make that clear with
your fellow audience members so let's
get started what I'm going to talk about
is the last decade in JavaScript and
three revolutions that began in the last
decade and all three of these are still
in progress now you might think this is
a real talk through history but in fact
what you're going to see is these three
revolutions many of you have not
embraced them yet despite the fact that
they've been around for a while I find
it pretty cool that today is exactly 10
years since Jeff Atwood coined Atwoods
law which says any application that can
be written in JavaScript will be written
in JavaScript now when I would said this
I thought it sounded pretty cray
despite being a guy that's really big
into JavaScript this sounded nuts but
today we live in a world where that
really is a reality think about the web
was the beginning of JavaScript we all
know that that's where it started so yes
I can write web applications using j/s
but today I can write server side apps
using node.js I can write native mobile
apps using react native using native
script using PhoneGap and I can even
write desktop apps using things like
electron it's crazy to me that my
favorite editor today is vs code and
that is written in HTML Javascript and
CSS because it uses electron my favorite
way to communicate and share gifts with
my co-workers is slack that's again
written there's some slack fans here
there we go again that is written in
plain old JavaScript using electron
pretty amazing so Atwoods law has come
to fruition javascript I like to say
it's a lot like visa it's everywhere you
want to be but it's interesting a lot of
us are JavaScript developers not because
we believe the JavaScript is the best
language in the world we are in
JavaScript because of where it is not
what it is and JavaScript continues to
get better and I love seeing the fact
that now every year right around June we
get a new release of JavaScript with
goodness but I'm certainly a JavaScript
developer because I can write for any
platform and that's pretty amazing so
it's a really awesome future that we
have ahead with our skill sets so
anybody know what happened January 12
2010 this was the beginning of a key
phase of the JavaScript revolution the
reusable JavaScript revolution any
guesses jQuery nope jQuery was not then
it was actually earlier no it was drum
roll drum roll drum roll NPM NPM was
announced on 2010 that was the first
release of NPM pretty big deal now at
the time it didn't even make that big of
a splash because we already had things
like Bower that a lot of people were
using it was unclear
whether who and when people would be
using NPM but today NPM has swallowed
the world as JavaScript's de-facto
package manager and this is a key piece
of the reusable JavaScript revolution if
you haven't embraced in PM yet then
you're missing out on a lot of power now
the thing is if you rewind just two
years this was life as a developer this
was how I was spending my time if I yeah
I read some of the script tags as part
of fun but think about the pain that we
went through in 2008 just 2008 wasn't
that long ago I was dealing with all of
this pain look at what would happen oh I
want to go use someone else's work in
JavaScript well what steps would I go
through well I do something like this I
would search the web I'd read the docs
and go install this read the relevant
install steps I download any relevant
JavaScript and CSS I'd set up my script
tags my style references and then I'd
write some JavaScript that targets that
HTML then I'd realize it wouldn't work I
mean I'd wonder why didn't get a lot of
help at that part then I'd realized that
the Dom query that I wrote was wrong
that was a common mistake that I'd make
in this era and it still wouldn't work
might fix it still wouldn't work I'd
realize that the script order was wrong
so I dream a script tag because this
needs to load before this which loads
before this so I fixed that and it still
wouldn't work then I'd read the docs
some more and realize oh okay I'm
running the wrong version of jQuery I
found that buried down in here I need to
run at least this version so I go ahead
and update that and I would repeat all
of these steps to go update jQuery there
was no easy way for me to upgrade my
dependencies once this finally worked I
would typically drink heavily and that
was my 14 step process for working with
JavaScript in 2008 now if you want to
stay updated imagine this I just went
through all that work to get this going
if I want to stay updated what would I
do in that case I would repeat a lot of
those steps again very very painful and
what if I wanted to minify or bundle or
test this code nope not gonna happen not
practical in that era hardly any of us
were because it was just too hard
contrast that with today npm install'
lib import the library
npm update that's pretty cool that is
vastly vastly simpler that is worth
celebrating
javascript doesn't have a base class
library and because of that we're seeing
npm grow at an amazing rate NPM
effectively has filled in this gap and
in pians growth has been unprecedented
unprecedent you look at these lines here
you want to guess which one is NPM come
on y'all you're supposed to be the one
on the top it's kind of baiting you
there look at this so this number down
here this green line down here that is
dot Nets package manager which is nougat
they add 66 packages per day how about
Java's 139 per day
NPM almost 500 packages are added every
single day to NPM by the end of the day
another 500 things are out there I mean
that is amazing that's amazing unless
you factor in Sturgeon slaw it's always
a caveat with growth we I don't want to
pick on anybody but now I will say I
think sturgeon was a bit of a pessimist
because my take is even if sturgeons law
is true this is also true I mean more is
better ten percent of that crap is good
so that's it's a win yes I know I'm a
child but this is my this is my
justification now III really think this
is a glass-half-full mentality when you
have that sort of view it's a bit of a
first world problem kind of complaint oh
no I can't keep up with all this awesome
free stuff that people keep building for
me
I mean life as a JavaScript developer
when we talk about JavaScript fatigue we
sound a little it's hard to have a lot
of sympathy for us it's a bit like going
to a family reunion and complaining
about how your inbox is full of
recruiter emails oh another recruiter
wanting me to interview it's hard being
a developer your family will do not say
this at a family reunion you think
you're crazy
so we're in a great place as JavaScript
developers and my point is this
NPM allows us to write our code once and
then reuse it it's a very simple idea so
a question for the audience we're going
to go through this cadence through this
talk question for you how many of you
are using NPM packages today so that is
probably 70% of the room very good but I
have a more interesting question I was
expecting the majority of you to say
that you do how about this how many of
you will say my team has published in
NPM packages my team or my company
that's about ten fifteen percent of the
room although a noisy one whew yes we're
excited about this so look at this
everybody put your hands back up if you
have published an NPM package and Zack
your party in back there that's cool
so look around the room guys the future
is here it's just not evenly distributed
I believe that if I came back here in a
couple years we would see the vast
majority of hands up so ask yourself do
I want to join the revolution because it
is here now what would I share is a demo
that shows how my team works with NPM
packages my team maintains an NPM
package called fusion the fusions a
framework that we use for doing react
development and Cox Automotive it adds
many opinions in on exactly how we want
to do react development so if I click
over here I can go to our github
repository and you can see that this NPM
package of course has a package JSON and
what makes this package interesting is
all the dependencies that it holds
inside our our applications have a
single dependency which is fusion but
behind the scenes starting here at line
27 and scrolling down these are all the
dependencies that we're actually using
to put our applications to work so
developers don't have to make decisions
on webpack or babel or what react
dependencies they should be pulling in
they just leverage all of these packages
which are built in diffusion we also
include some build scripts that start
the application that configure our tests
and that perform the production build
we've also added some interesting
extensions
now behind the scenes we're actually
using create react app but we've added a
number of opinions on top to get this
done but through the power of this
single NPM package when we deploy
applications this is the up dependency
that our applications take on and in
that way when we change directions when
we need to do bug fixes or enhancements
to our build process or deployments
upgrade dependencies people have a
single NPM package that they can update
as necessary so that is the key point at
the end we have at this point published
at least a half dozen applications using
a single NPM package that we call fusion
so those applications you go into the
package.json you know you find there
one dependency because we've decided as
a company that will bundle up all of our
dependencies behind the scene it's about
75 NPM packages a number of build
scripts all of that is contained through
the power of NPM
so I'd encourage you to consider that
pattern so that was the first revolution
which is the package revolution this is
the very foundation of the reusable
JavaScript revolution that I'm talking
about today so you need to have accepted
that before you move on to phase 2 phase
2 of the reusable JavaScript revolution
I call starter kits or I also like to
call this part deux so if you were
coding back in the day jQuery versus
mootools versus prototype j/s which I
did there was a funny site called
vanilla Jas and you would go out to
vanilla Jas and build your own custom
download you could select things like
Ajax event system functions as
first-class objects do regular
expressions I want those in an array
library that sounds handy and then I
could build a custom download of all
these features in this vanilla Jas
library and when I opened it in my
editor what I would see is an empty file
do you get the punchline
vanilla Jas is using the platform and if
you went through the vanilla GS website
what they would do is contrast the
performance of plain vanilla Jas versus
using jQuery or mootools and they would
point out vanilla Jas was not
surprisingly faster because it removed a
layer of abstraction
and this was funny at the time and
caught some level of attention however I
believe that vanilla Jas is malpractice
and I believe that because today as
developers if we're not leveraging each
other's work we are wasting time we are
reinventing the wheel we should be
standing on the shoulders of giants and
so many of us in here have done good
work see today here's the story so many
of us are expecting to publish an
application to the web with a single
minified bundle
maybe tree shaking maybe that bundle is
split in ways so that it loads from page
to page that's not trivial you want
things like explicit dependencies you
want it to be Mart modular minified
transpiled lint it tested you want an
automated build and you want automated
updates
I believe that file new project is
malpractice and in my organization we do
not do file new project when we start
from scratch we are starting from a
foundation with literally over 75
different opinions baked into it it is a
huge number of opinions that we have
think about some of the decisions that
you make if you're gonna file new
project right now as a JavaScript
developer you as a team need to decide
what editor are we going to use and how
we standardize that configuration of
tabs versus spaces line endings and as
such what NPM package or I should say
what package manager are we going to use
because NPM isn't the only one but it's
a pretty logical choice what development
web server will we use what automation
approach what transpiler what bundler
what winter how about automated testing
we need to choose a framework an
assertion library helper libraries where
to run our tests when to run them and
where to place these files we need to
choose a CI server if we're making HTTP
calls Ajax that sort of thing we need to
choose an HTTP call approach in fact if
I lay all this out on a slide it's very
difficult to fit it all and here's
what's interesting you're gonna watch
all these decisions fly by you here but
ask yourself this if you did a file new
project would you remember to ask
yourself these questions would you
remember all of
concerns because as a group in here we
know that testing is important we know
that minification and bundling and
transpiling are all important as
JavaScript developers but it's really
easy for a lot of these decisions to hit
the floor it's easy to accidentally end
up in production in a bad state if you
don't automate it away so again I say
vanilla JavaScript today is malpractice
file new project is malpractice start
from something more opinionated and so
what I'm driven by is a level of
dissatisfaction with the current state
of affairs in JavaScript I can't get no
satisfaction
so here's where's what I'm dissatisfied
with rework I don't want to start from
scratch when I'm starting a new project
I don't want a tedious set up just so I
can get to a HelloWorld wiring up
transpiling and bundling and
minification all of these things is
really tricky and I end up repeating
mistakes how about this you read a blog
post and this blog post goes oh man this
is something I have to remember to do on
my next project but how do you remember
to do that later the way that you do
that is to codify your opinions the
solution that I am suggesting here is to
codify your opinions now one way that
you can codify your opinions is through
a checklist if you've ever added the
book checklist manifesto I highly
recommend this to developers it's not a
technical book but what it drives home
is the benefits of writing down what you
need to do see the checklist manifesto
tells an interesting story about doctors
we as developers we don't like checklist
because we feel like I'm a professional
I don't need a checklist I know what to
do off the top of my head but doctors
have been found that to need a checklist
there was a study that found this you go
in you have the nurses ask the doctors
the steps that they need to perform
before they cut a hole in your body and
run a tube into it they're gonna run a
line into you they have to make sure
that they sit down they wash their hands
properly that they make the incision
properly that they cover their hands and
gloves it's not very many steps but as a
doctor in the heat of the moment it's
really easy to forget a step and what
they found was a percentage of the time
that happened and what happens in that
case is people die people die when you
miss a step now thankfully lives
generally aren't in our hands but
increasingly that is happening in
software too they saw dramatic results
by creating checklists what they saw was
the 10 day line infection rate fell from
11% to zero because how could you miss
it if you do the proper steps
people don't get infections because you
have protected yourself from it the
checklist prevented 43 infections eight
deaths and two million dollars in costs
so in summary doctors know what to do
but it's easy to overlook a step and in
the same way we as developers also know
what to do but I showed you that slide
deck there were probably everything on
that slide deck you thought yeah I'm
generally familiar with that but do you
ask yourself those 40 questions every
time you start a new JavaScript project
have you asked yourself that about your
existing project today probably not so
on my team we have honored this
checklist idea we've created a file
called pull request template MD here's a
little pro tip if you use github create
a file with this name and every time
somebody creates a pull request it will
generate this within the pull request so
that way all of our pull requests have
our code review checklist right there
inside of it automatically that's us
embracing the checklist manifesto so
that we make sure we don't skip a step
however you're a developer so an even
better idea than this is to automate it
strive to automate and I think this is a
really important principle that the more
things that you can take for granted the
better off you are Society advances as
we can take things for granted the fact
that we came here today and we could
take for granted that these lights would
be on that my computer would be charged
up that I could get in a car and drive
here that's really important in the same
way as developers we need to increase
the list of things that we can take for
granted see on my team there's a long
list of things that we just don't think
about anymore my team knows that they
can use the latest version of JavaScript
they know that it will just magically
get transpiled they don't have to think
about it in any way they know that every
time that they hit save the tests will
run automatically and when we push code
it will end up running on the CI server
and we'll know if any tests have failed
we know in our code reviews that bar
code reviews go really fast now because
most of the things that we look for are
caught by linters instead of manually on
a case-by-case basis
we know that when we get to production
we'll be able to use source maps to
debug our code even though we're
transpiling we'll be able to see our
original code in production we can start
our application with one command when
somebody joins my team you clone the
repository you say npm start and magic
happens and you're seeing your code
there's no special work there we know
that we can run a build that's minified
bundled ready for production by just
saying npm run build and we know that to
get to production you say npm run deploy
all of this is taken for granted and
when you can take all of this stuff for
granted it's awesome because then you
can focus on the hard problems and
programming see this basics this
plumbing that we're talking about here
should not be burning your cycles it
should be a solved problem for your team
and I assert this that the more that we
can take for granted the faster we will
move and the higher the quality we'll be
on our projects so I think of a starter
kit as a living automated and
interactive checklist and increases the
number of things that you can take for
granted now a lot of you may feel like
well I kind of have a starter kit I went
out and I used create react app from
Facebook or I use the angular CLI or I
used ember CLI whatever maybe well I
believe that that's not enough my
recommendation to you go find a project
like that for kit make it your own and
then add your opinions in because I
guarantee you your team has a number of
other opinions on top of those tools and
that's precisely what my team has done
we use create react app behind the
scenes but we have added many many more
opinions on top of it now this is a
really big conversation I published a
five-hour course on Pluralsight called
building a JavaScript development
environment where I talk through all of
those 40 decisions and how you reason
about those but my recommendation to you
is really simple when you get back to
your office on Monday I would suggest
this to you just schedule a meeting
schedule a meeting with your team and
say I want to have a adult conversation
about the issues let's just sit together
and talk this through and we'll come to
an agreement on how we do JavaScript
here at our company
and I think it'll go well now often
these conversations can get heated
because typescript versus Babel is a big
big deal people feel very very strongly
we've been through this as well but I
don't believe this
I believe if you're having those kinds
of tabs versus spaces conversations on
every JavaScript project you're spending
a lot of time in the wrong place as a
team come together and agree and then
you can move forward so I want to share
another demo I want to show you our
starter kit that we use at Cox
Automotive this is my team starter kit
which we call fusion the way that it
works is you clone the repository just
like you would any other github repo I
already have it cloned over here after
you have cloned it you run NPM run setup
and setup helps you first install all
the packages automatically and after
those packages are installed then it
will prompt you for the settings it will
ask you if you want to delete the git
repository I'm just going to leave it as
is here and then it will prompt you for
your project name as you can see it
enforces a logical name for a
package.json it'll ask you for whatever
version you'd like to assign for the
author of the project it will ask you
for your production URL I'll just put my
URL comm ask you for your license the
project description just the demo and
now that we're done our setup is
complete if I come over to package.json
then I can see that it added this
information into the repository and we
have a few scripts in here to get
started the other thing that's
interesting is that our starter kit has
a single NPM package dependency so we
can make changes over time and all any
deployed applications need to do is pull
a new version of fusion and they get all
those bug fixes or new enhancements in
the future now when you run our starter
kit what you will see what you see is it
starts up a demo application that says
welcome to fusion gives you links to
important information like
our list of reusable components our
style guide and some basic steps that
you can run once you're done looking at
this demo you can run this script to
remove the demo but we also show people
how to work with a Redux app so you can
go behind the scenes and see how this
simple demo application works that just
calculates miles per gallon we show how
our form validation story works in an
interactive way and again you can see
that many of our opinions on forms are
all encapsulated within our reusable
components we show how our mock API
works so you can actually come into here
and save your changes and when you save
those changes you'll see that they're
reflected even when you reload the page
we show how to dynamically import
libraries and we also show how to lazy
load heavy react components so you can
see that this loaded after the fact now
once I'm done and comfortable with this
demo I can go ahead and remove it and
get started coding to do that I come
over here and say NPM run remove demo
and when I do we can see that there's a
lot fewer files over here now and if I
rerun the application now it's simply a
hello world so we have a simple starting
point that is ready to run the app so
that's how we do development on my team
the nice thing is everybody knows that
they start with Fusion starters what
we've called it one thing I will
recommend is choose a brand name for
whatever you do I was recently out in
San Jose consulting a team that went for
the same model and they chose their own
special name they called theirs preamp
because they have a model where they're
tied to videos and they like that idea
of a preamp it went well with their
branding had their own logo and
everything now
unfortunately what I just showed you
isn't open source so you can't go out
there and dig through it for more but a
very very similar project that I
published about a year and a half ago
was reactive slingshots so if you want
to dig through the code and see how all
this works
check out react slingshot just yesterday
it hit seven thousand stars so I was
pretty excited about that it's gotten a
lot of usage so I'm excited about this
this is an opinionated way to work with
react that's said I'm a big fan of
create react app - it's a awesome
solution so question how many of you
will say that my team are
bini has its own JavaScript starter kit
Wow
so that is four percent not five four
I'm that exact with my count so that is
a very very small number so again look
around the room the future is here it's
just not evenly distributed I believe
that this is the future because starting
with final new project is just too much
work and your team has a large set of
opinions there are over 40 decisions
that you need to make when you file new
project on JavaScript today and a
starter kit operates as an automated
checklist for your team so that you can
codify your opinions and automate all
the fatigue that people talk about away
my team is not fatigued anymore we know
when we start a project that's what it
looks like and it just works we don't
have conversations about the basics
anymore
all right so we have talked about two of
the three reusable resolutions packages
and starter kits I'm going to close out
this talk with the final revolution
which is reusable components all of
these build upon one another now for
those that aren't familiar with
reasonable components it's a reusable
piece of HTML Javascript and CSS and we
know that these are the big reasons that
we want consistency less code faster
development fewer bugs the component
model gives us these obvious benefits at
Facebook they are heavily invested in
the component model using react and they
find that components helped hundreds of
engineers work on the same codebase move
between teams quickly ramp up and focus
on products now this has happened all
over the world I'm and I'm a car guy I
work for an automotive software company
in fact back in Kansas City and you look
at this Mercedes this is a beautiful car
and you think okay these are a bunch of
special parts inside but in actuality
there's all sorts of reusable pieces
reusable components inside here the seat
belt the button on the seat belt the
airbag systems the transmissions the but
the engines themselves in many cases are
used across vehicles really large
complicated components and this cuts
their costs at speeds development and
increases economies of scale as
developers we have all this same power
now we should be working with higher and
higher level abstractions with better
components as time goes on that's
precisely what's happening on my team
now we've created our basic
so now we're starting to build on top of
those basic building blocks I will tell
you this I believe that the future of
development is going to be assembling
finished components taking those
components putting them together in
novel ways we'll be thinking of
ourselves more like working with LEGO
pieces rather than having to build the
Legos ourselves leverage higher pieces
higher levels of abstraction now I wish
I could claim this slide but I love how
this slide encapsulates the mindset
shift that you need to make today as a
JavaScript developer for the longest
time we've talked about separation of
concerns as a separation of JavaScript
HTML and CSS I don't believe that's a
valid way to think about separation of
concerns anymore because separation of
concerns today is a matter of components
so I want to separate my concern of this
button from my concern of a date picker
from my concern of this modal dialogue
the component is the concern we're
separating it's a powerful idea because
you recognize that HTML and JavaScript
were never separated concerns we thought
they were back in the jQuery days I
would write unobtrusive javascript
here's my HTML here's my JavaScript the
problem was if I ever changed my HTML I
broke my application if I didn't also
update my JavaScript because my
JavaScript was hard-coded expecting a
certain Dom to be there this is the
important future for JavaScript
developers is thinking about concerns in
terms of reusable components and those
components may be composed of multiple
technologies but separating technologies
doesn't necessarily separate concerns
HTML and JavaScript are fundamentally
intertwined now there's an interesting
question that someone might ask you
though if I asked you hey can you share
this HTML with me that's a surprisingly
hard question to answer I don't know
quite how I respond to it I love I will
tell you this is the hardest thing about
writing talks is getting distracted by
stock photography and all the silliness
that you see you guys couldn't turn the
monitor on before you pointed at it yeah
but this is a hard question can you
share this HTML with me and the really
the answer is we don't share raw HTML
what we share instead is JavaScript that
embeds HTML so if I want to share this
div with you the way that I'm going to
get it done is with JavaScript and
has been the case throughout history
over the years we've seen a lot of ways
to get this done and this brings us to
the third and final revolution which
actually occurred earlier but I'm
introducing it last for a specific
reason that I'll explain in a moment now
what happened on this date in 2006 no
guesses web components nope that was
later gmail web app that's an
interesting guess no although that's
that's close that was that was in the
ballpark jQuery there we go
yes jQuery was launched in 2006 this was
a very big deal this this is what kept
me from ragequitting web development I
was just about done with it because
cross-browser was so painful and jQuery
wasn't really about components jQuery
was about paving over inconsistencies in
the DOM and giving you a really elegant
API but very shortly after jQuery came
about we saw this jQuery plugins and
jQuery plugins were really the first
popular way to build reusable components
for the web
however today you're likely not going to
reach for jQuery plugins to get this
done today we're all asking ourselves
how should I build components now I
obviously have an opinion on this matter
and in fact I'm going to go ahead and
share it but I want caveat why I believe
that strong opinions are useful for
others those who are undecided or
ambivalent can just adopt your stance
but those who disagree can solidify
their stance by arguing against yours so
I would totally encourage you tonight
we're gonna have an after party I'd love
for you to come up and say how I'm a
dummy head and you feel like this other
thing is better that's absolutely fine
I'll share my opinion on this story
right now because there is no really
clear answer web components the web
components standard is a compelling
option to consider here now I'm a big
fan of standardization if you're not
familiar with web components it's this
idea of four core technologies inert
templates put some markup in there and
it just works custom elements where you
can define your own HTML elements shadow
Dom which encapsulates your style so
they don't leak out and imports being
able to bundle HTML Javascript and CSS
now I'm a big fan of standards and I
even created a course on html5 web
components on Pluralsight because I was
really amped about this standard now the
sad news is I can't stand up here and
push you you might think that
what I'm going to tell you right now is
go ahead go use web components but the
story really isn't that simple there's a
few reasons that I'm not reaching for
web components and many of you how many
of you are using native web components
one hand one hand out of I don't know
how many that's that's definitely a less
than one percent here's why
spotty browser support so you have to
pull in polyfills in those polyfills way
a substantial amount yesterday I just
learned I believe it was 27 K minified
for the polyfills that you need for IE
11 for instance to be able to run the
standard and that's because of browser
support see the template tag is pretty
well supported cross browser except for
IE you'll need a polyfill there but the
other three core technologies not so
HTML imports a lot of read custom
elements shadow dom and we have been
waiting i've literally been waiting for
years for browsers to implement these
standards and we're still waiting so the
question is when there are two other
issues here this at the time I was
really excited about web components
because it enabled some new things the
idea of the shadow Dom was really novel
that I could write simple CSS selectors
and not worry about leaking on to other
components but today javascript
libraries they keep on innovating so in
fact I compared to react for instance
react has answers to all these things
JSX for templates react components are
effectively your custom element you can
use CSS modules or CSS and j/s to keep
your Styles tied to that one component
and we're all using bundlers and NPM
anyway so we don't really need the HTML
import specification so my take on it is
this don't wait around for the web
standard to catch on instead just
embrace modern JavaScript the real
question is which framework so these are
the four most popular although there are
many more options out there that I'm not
going to try to fit on a slide here's
what I think you should be asking
yourself though for things how stable is
it how broadly is it adopted how much
boilerplate am I putting in here that's
specific to this library that's gonna
make it hard to shift to something else
later and how much does it weigh so I'm
a big fan of react I'll be completely
honest about that let's see how it
scores here we're in react you do code
mods when there's a
change a major release I just run a
codemod that automates it for me and
that's because Facebook has to do that
they are dogfooding in a way that no one
else can compare to Facebook comm one of
the biggest sites in the world uses
30,000 react components so Facebook
can't afford to make a big braking
change that requires manual changes
they'd have to update 30,000 components
fundamentally react is a function that
returns HTML it is very low boilerplate
and finally it's quite lightweight 43k
gzipped
now I may change my mind tomorrow and if
you go see me talking at conferences on
videos from previous years you'll find
I've had different stickers on my laptop
from year to year this is how my
trajectory has been through history I
was using angular not that long ago but
now I'm enjoying react at the moment
next year I may be somewhere else
so you do have to ask yourself this what
if I choose X and everybody moves to Y
whether regardless of where you are
chances are there's going to be some
other new hotness coming soon my take on
it is this if you choose a low boiler
point a low boiler plate library then
you can get started safely today
migration really is practical see for
instance here's react there's really
very little boilerplate I've got to have
an import at the top I have a function
with a name that takes parameters and it
returns HTML if you told my team hey
Cory your team needs to go rewrite
everything in view wait you totally do
that that's not a big deal it's mostly a
syntactic change I don't burn the world
to the ground because really this is
what's hard component design is hard but
coding isn't that big of a deal I'm
convinced that my team it would be
relatively straightforward for us to
move to a new technology later when
react is no longer the new hotness
whatever that may be and it may very
well be us moving to standardize web
components once all of the browsers have
really embraced the standard but I don't
believe that you should sit around and
wait because centralized and consistent
is most certainly preferable to
decentralized and inconsistent now
that's not always true but in the
aggregate repeating yourself through
copy and paste is not a design pattern
that scales very well now choosing a
framework is just one of many decisions
that you have to consider here I showed
you something like this when you were
thinking about building a starter kit
there is a similarly ridiculously long
list here and I'm just going to jump
ahead so you don't have to watch it all
go fifty decisions 52
that you need to consider when you're
going to create a reusable component
library so that is huge again I went
through the same thing I just published
a course if you happen to be interested
in react called creating reusable react
components this is a six hour course I
thought that I could get it done in two
but it is a complicated conversation
because there are this many decisions to
consider 50 different ones so I want to
show you quickly how we do reusable
components at Cox Automotive this is our
documentation for fusion UI components
along the left-hand side we have a
alphabetized list of components I'm
looking at the text input component
right now which is an abstraction over a
label a text input and error message and
add some opinions around that down here
we have a list of examples for each of
these examples you can click on the
examples header and see a snippet of
code that you could copy and paste into
an application down at the bottom we
also have a list of props which you can
change to oh I apologize I hit the
attract pad so I will narrate this
anyway just to save us some time but the
thing that I want to emphasize is one of
the harder parts is setting up your
documentation setting it up in a way
that is leveraging all your code and
what we have is all the documentation
that I'm showing you here is generated
from the code we add these comments see
the comments over there on the left it's
kind of a j/s doc style comment that's
what generates our documentation so
every time we hit save in the code we
see our documentation change and that
way we don't have to worry about the two
getting out of sync I show how to get
this done in the Pluralsight course on
react components really the patterns
that I follow would apply just as well
as an angular developer or view
developer don't build your Doc's by hand
automate that process so final question
how many of you have your own reusable
component library more hands than I
expected this is great that's probably
15 percent of the room that's pretty
cool excellent how many of you are
working in angular for that reusable
component library okay how many
unreactive you any Wow so view and
reactor neck-and-neck here that's very
different than Kansas well I'll find out
Kansas City next month the KCDC we'll
see how much that is shifted I know
views getting a lot of attention
okay so very very interesting so we just
saw that again everybody with their
hands raised that's an interesting take
as we've gone through this progression
fewer and fewer people are through these
three revolutions because one revolution
builds on another so let's go ahead and
wrap up I want to clarify why I laid all
of this talk out in the order that I did
when you're gonna build a house with
components you're gonna go out and get a
chimney component a door a window these
sorts of things you want to you don't
want to start from scratch and build
your own window or your own door and
this should be the story now today with
your development story on your team but
to be able to do this you need a
foundation a house can't float in the
air the foundation that I'm suggesting
for you is a starter kit that starter
kit encapsulates all the dependencies
that your team needs and of course that
starter kit gets hosted on NPM and
that's precisely why I laid out the
reusable revolution in the order that I
did so if you're one of those people
that likes to take pictures of slides at
conferences your big chance just make
sure your camera's not pointed at your
face first was the NPM packages so the
reusable revolution of packages my call
to you is create your first package we
just saw about 30% of the room has not
created an NPM package before so that's
a big first step in fact no I take that
back it was more like 60% of the room
but not starter kits my call to you is
codify your decisions set up a meeting
on Monday to say let's come to an
agreement as a team here's how we do
lending here's how we do bundling here's
how we do transpiling
etc automate the pain away and finally
with it comes to reusable components go
pick a library and start sharing set up
a centralized site and start documenting
your work so if you're gonna take a
picture here's your big chance right
here so hopefully I've shared a vision
that gets you as excited as I am I come
into work each day and I'm just awesome
I'm ready to go I am amped to be a
JavaScript developer I really life is
pretty good for us right now there's
this reusable revolution is taking off I
am HealthCorps on Twitter I'd love a
tweet of feedback thank you all for
listening
[Applause]